foreign
great so for our next talk and for the
um
talking about some I think very recent
work on lost minimization and
multi-calibration in large
thank you uh thank you for inviting me
uh this is Joint work with these great
co-authors Udi would have been a
co-author but since he left we've
decided to remove him
and so his talk was like this will be
extra light and conceptual uh and I'd
love to have questions during the talk
so feel free to ask
um so uh let me just start with the
boosting because as you all know
multi-calibration is related to boosting
and it's uh boosting is kind of like the
predecessor or the easy version and
there's some classifiers if you're
learning half spaces
um you can definitely get better
classifier by boosting them obviously or
as many people know here's an example
where there's no good classic there's no
good half space for learning this but if
you were to boost half spaces you would
probably learn this perfectly
to separate that positive negatives
um uh but uh you don't really see as
much work on uh say boosting large
neural networks
um and you know well that would be
expensive because you need many of the
neural networks of course uh but
um there there's another reason we say
which is that like uh what does boosting
do one of the simplest forms of boosting
the shabiri's original version of
boosting was uh it just took a majority
of three classifiers you took you
trained one classifier on your data then
you train the second classifier on a mix
of the correct and uh incorrect examples
equally weighted in a third classifier
where those two disagreed and you took
the majority of these and that worked
great and there's a lot of boosting
algorithms that work by just taking the
majority of classifiers it's good enough
um so and the majority function is you
can write it as a neural network too
so instead of you know training uh a
neural network in this way of you know
training several neural networks in
specific ways and thinking majority you
could just train a larger neural network
and if you could optimize perfectly
overall neural networks this should do
only better
right does that make sense
foreign
so optimizing a large neural network
should be boosting small neural networks
uh if especially if you could find
global optimums there is something you
can say in the case where you can't that
I'll mention later
um if we have time so just formally if
you had the family of neural networks of
size said most s nodes and you can uh
it's not very important but there's some
details of what the activations are in
the neural network then the most
accurate neural network with end nodes
is as accurate as a boosting if you have
a number of iterations iterate times the
size of the smaller neural network
basically okay that's exactly what I
said here so that's kind of the warm-up
and the fact is that uh I claim I was I
checked with GPT for this morning
uh so that that you know you don't see
that much boosting with neural networks
uh and so gpt4 said in general boosting
is not commonly used together with deep
neural networks and it has a long
explanation uh school which I was
satisfied with because it confirmed what
I wanted g53.5 disagreed but it wasn't
as good as this gp4 okay so uh okay so
the outline is uh you know we talked
about uh boosting uh neural networks and
um uh and now I want to talk about it
with respect to a similar thing with
respect to multi calibrations would be
slightly more complicated but the same
idea and then uh I'll talk about some
related work and this is where I'll get
fund is the conceptual discussion is
like you know how does this what does
this mean what do we take away from this
so uh
um the claim is that larger neural
networks don't necessarily need
multi-calibration uh and similar to the
boosting so yeah well let's say we're in
a binary classification setting or
aggression setting and we're trying to
learn some function from X to Y and
we're minimizing squared error so then
uh we want to uh no I wasn't here
yesterday and I'm sure they were like a
gazillion forms of multi-calibration
presented I hope so I hope this was one
of them
um but I don't really want to go into
the definition of multicolibration the
specific definition of multi calibration
we have what's interesting here is we
say uh we're going to have a notion of
alpha multi-calibration for some
parameter Alpha between zero and one and
what we would like to say is oh if we
could perfectly minimize over neural
networks of size n then we would be uh
multi-calibrated with respect to smaller
neural networks so that the tests
themselves will also be neural networks
but they'll be smaller and we'd like to
get that but
um it's not quite true for all neural
network sizes for a reason that I'll
explain in a second
um but it is true for many neural
network sizes okay there's a some number
of neural network sizes which might not
be true for but all a finite number of
them and so depending on this parameter
Alpha and the size of the small test
neural networks s it'll be through
beyond that so basically if you want to
get something multi-calibrated it would
be good enough to choose a neural
network size it's pretty big if you want
to be multi-calibrated with the
respective set known exercise s and you
choose a you know random one in some
range that's much bigger than this range
than with high probability it'll be
multicolored
do you not know that you know some size
that's you know oh guys it's sufficient
do we not know what's it again they're
saying for at most yes there's many
interviewers like it almost sounds like
you know you know there could be some
like arbitrarily oh it's a huge one like
randomly yeah yeah uh the next slide
which has a proof will shed light on
Executive
but it could be as far as our analysis
goes that the the bad ones are like fire
out but you can actually check and see
whether you're uh whether you're
multi-calibrated or not uh
well uh if you could actually
efficiently minimize perfectly
um so uh this yeah
is very uh boring uh simple one where
it's just a dag it's just like uh any uh
dag architecture and then the nodes
could be connected arbitrarily to the
lower ones and we're counting the
numbers I mean maybe for this but
absolutely that's not the case if it
should just be a shame
it could be I'm saying no I'm saying
we're optimizing over all neural
networks with s nodes
[Music]
it would be interesting we didn't really
look into it to consider how the
relationship between the large
architecture and small architecture we
just did this for Simplicity
so
it's painful but how does it correspond
to the
video
networks failing then
calibrate them but
um
too much
yes
I can ask the expert I think they've
trained with different data so they use
different data to do the adjustment yeah
yeah so this is generally the problem of
gender shape is that I thought my
impression was that it was a lack of
beta uh which is what you're saying like
there wasn't enough uh training data for
minority groups uh but also when you
know which group you care about
sometimes you can also Focus your loss
more there like multi calibration
weights the groups based on their
representation of data right effectively
the point of that what we're optimizing
over here you're saying like it's not
saying that that uh SGD on the Pixar I'm
sure it's kind of fine it's often
saying that there exists an obstacles
sufficiently large size but but I had
something to say about it yeah but um
yeah but I think that the
that's sort of an ignorant question
um when you train neural Nets in general
are they even globally calibrated
uh do typically you're asking or you're
like I mean for example the gpt4 paper
that recently came out uh showed a
beautiful calibration curve uh on its
weights but that's just the one example
and I'm sure there's exceptions you know
they're probably our case there might be
cases you know I'm following the general
trend is not to boost neural networks or
to applied multi calibration maybe there
are exceptions that would be super
interesting to look into why uh that's
happening
yes thank you
great questions
so and the proof which uh it's very
simple is the basic idea is we say look
suppose you're not multi-calibrated
suppose there's some test C which uh is
a small neural network which
demonstrates that your best neural
network of size and FN star
um you know let's just say we could
exactly minimize loss for a second
suppose that that was the case then uh
there exists some better neural network
which kind of substitute which kind of
combines these two with some
simple logic there and some weights um
it only takes like three nodes I'm not
going to show you what it is but it's
not complicated that that larger neural
network which is the size of n plus C
plus three
um we'll have error loss squared error
Alpha squared lower than yours okay I
think this is implicit probably in
various Works um so we're just you know
an interpretation of that is saying oh
look so now okay this means this is kind
of interesting so first of all you know
this function you could just look at the
loss of the network the best network of
size n for every n and if if your
network is lost is not much uh bigger
than what you get if you take a larger
Network so if there's not too big a drop
if you look at the drop in uh the loss
this answers the question uh your
question from before uh so you know
you're in good shape if you compare your
loss to the best loss with a slightly
larger larger Network and there's not a
huge drop if the drop isn't bigger than
Alpha squared then you know that your
multi-calibrate Alpha multi-calibrated
with respect to the smaller networks so
whatever this last function looks like
you know it's got some it's decree it's
not it's definitely not increasing
because it's the best neural network of
size n
um
so there could be at most one over Alpha
squared drops of magnitude Alpha squared
let's say if you just check neural
networks of size multiples of s plus
three and then you could do this forever
every uh mod uh s plus three for each
one and then you get the statement that
there's at most this is the number of
bad networks but also you get the
statement that this is like a way to
test and confirm but they could be I
mean it could weirdly be that the loss
goes out here and then drops
weirdly at some random size uh that you
happen to pick exactly I mean the sizes
that people use are billions or hundreds
of billions or trillions of nodes so
it's unlikely that you would hit on that
one but it's possible
we actually have another way but you
could do this test you could train two
Network sizes to see whether you're
actually at that weird point or you can
also use regularization uh to get around
this and choose a neural network size
that minimizes some combination of loss
and uh
so
um okay
um
so let me just mention uh a couple other
related works but if there are any
questions on this or that discussion is
very important about the interpretation
so my my sense but that's where like you
know it'd be great to have the expertise
of the audience here is that uh
that
you may not need multi empirically I I'm
not like aware of a ton of work which
combines it so my sense is that if you
have a weak classifier like a half space
weak and something it's not uh that
doesn't compose with itself right if you
uh it's not closed under composition
then you're gonna get
um Magic by multi-calibration and you
can actually you know you get these
branching programs of course those are
basically networks too kind of like
neural networks it's all circuits so
you've got another way to uh generate a
large network with some provable
guarantees maybe not as good in practice
or it doesn't seem to be as popular in
practice but uh um but you get the fear
guarantees whereas if what your base
classifier is is neural networks not
clear you you need this
okay
so you're searching over not just
parameters
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah so uh okay so let me uh just
mention a fun uh a fun thing that that
I'm working on now with Santosh Impala
um which is
related and technique uh but it's for
different problem but there's a lot of
parallels here
um for the question people are wondering
why do these language models work for
next word prediction they seem to train
them only to predict the next word and
magically they generate fluid text
um so uh it seems like outcome in uh
indistinguishability a little bit but I
I wasn't here for your talk yesterday so
that's my I'm not that not 100 confident
in this Slide the other side
um so uh uh so the parallel here is you
know uh if you train an expert
prediction it seems uh that you it looks
apparently like you get texts that seems
kind of indistinguishable from real Tech
from real text that people write to just
qualitatively I mean
um and uh that's kind of the goal of
outcoming distinguishability as well in
terms of the label
um there's a kind of trivial statement
you can say which is the true
distribution of text uh fits in your
family of neural networks with some size
then you should actually find the best
one and you've got the distributions if
there's some true distribution over text
it documents on the web are drawn from
some distribution IID and their that
distribution the next word distribution
is exactly a neural network with at most
175 billion parameters life is good you
should find that with you know some
amount of data and uh and then you
really get something statistically
indistinguishable and I think that would
probably probably have some statement
like that in terms of OI as well if
you're if you're a classifier have your
base optimal classifier happens to be
perfect classifier happens to be in the
family then you should learn that and it
should just be indistinguishable
specifically the hard case the
interesting case is when of course the
real distribution is not exactly in your
family
um and what we show here is something uh
there's basically we're using a similar
technique and then one other trick to
say okay well if you look at what these
uh language models do they complete a
free prefix you give it some text and
they generate them that they go on and
what we can show is that you won't be
able to distinguish based on the next
constant number of words
um
you know real completions from uh what
your neural network generates so a
constant number of words is good for
generating stuff that looks grammatical
it's probably not good for proving
theorems and that is actually what you
see with these language models like they
generate fluent things they have some
good ideas but probably at least so far
they're not generating correct proofs
and we kind of expect that you might
need some more ideas
um
uh here I don't think you have that same
limitation of the next so many words
um
but I do think there was like a paper
that lost optimization gives you somehow
some kind of indistinguishability
um but I'm not an expert on this anyway
so that was kind of one fun thing
um another thing to mention uh uh uh
that you know I think it's relevant to
this to this meeting is uh fair for
fairness sometimes you do uh there's a
there's tricky cases In fairness where
you don't know what the groups are right
but there's other ways to figure out
what the groups could be so here's a
paper uh joint with an in several
interns who are great great high school
students in a postback and what we try
to do here is figure out what the groups
are we had a we want to use uh let's say
we wanted to
um do an application of uh advertising
jobs to people
really it's what you're saying so you
know we want to advertise jobs to people
uh and we're worried about being biased
and what are the groups maybe age maybe
race we don't know so what we do is we
take a word embedding which is just uh
which is underlying still even today's
uh huge language models which gives you
a vector for every word in the language
and hundreds of thousands of Dimensions
I'll show you in two dimensions and you
could just cluster all the words in the
word embedding and then
um
they cluster beautifully and then you
can take one of the Clusters which will
be all the names and these are these are
real clusters I'm not making this up and
then you just cluster subcluster these
cluster the cluster of names and you get
these groups that pop out and the groups
are you can do statistics on them and
they are meaningful this is my family
the Israelis
um my my mother the older white uh
cluster of names and then you have
African-American names you have younger
older you have clusters by religion and
so on so this gives you a way to get a
handle on some kind of semantically
meaningful clusters just by looking at
the first names
um and then you can kind of see actually
the biases very clearly in the embedding
you can take you can take the cluster of
food and overlay it on top of these uh
things and you actually get uh it just
kind of spits out all these stereotypes
and associations the Israelis dewy
kosher hummus and bagels and a bunch of
other associations
um much more problematic is if you look
at the job associations it has here
um you know it's fine for the Israelis
to have these stereotypes but you don't
want to be associated with being a
Jailer or a shopkeeper or stuff uh based
on your name and people were using these
uh word embeddings in classification
tests where they're trying to uh you
know get some of these resume and rank
them or choose a job for them and they
weren't even removing the names but even
if you do remove the names it doesn't
totally correct for problems because
often you can kind of infer somebody's
gender or race or so on so anyway so uh
one thing that's uh we do that I don't
want to talk about but that is common is
you know you try to equate accuracy
across different groups or sometimes you
even want to do affirmative action and
that's something that's not uh you're
not going to get with monthly
calibration because uh it's hard to do
affirmative action if the groups are
arbitrary and you don't know what the
groups are and so this gives you a way
to kind of come up with groups and then
you can try to make sure accuracy is
equal among the different groups can I
ask something about how these jobs
like there's not that many super malls
right
like do you have some sense about
fat doctor
um you know the word embedding isn't
perfect like uh so uh what you can do is
if you do take uh jobs from the Bureau
of Labor Statistics and overlay them
then you get this way these are probably
jobs that we got by taking the cluster
of Words which were in the job cluster
of words
um so there's a lot of noise I mean
supervisor is a legitimate job uh
I agree with you that there's not a lot
of supermodels but it may be talked
about on the web a lot so maybe a high
frequency word yeah
anyway I mean this is just an example so
um uh so basically the high level
question is when does last uh
oh yeah with my point let me jump in
here because this is kind of uh my point
this is backwards so basically uh
some groups are more important than
others uh in some applications so in
some applications you really want to
make sure like my sister is a scientist
she hates it when she goes to a job site
and they advertise to her all kinds of
irrelevant administrator jobs but maybe
you know given her given that she's
female uh you know and maybe given the
information they have about her that's
the most accurate prediction they could
make but maybe you want to do some
re-weighting to make sure that you know
the female scientists are being shown
more jobs appropriate to them so you're
not
um compounding the problem and that's uh
this issue of compounding injustices
which is sort of that uh Hellman says
it's it's the groups that you want to
protect are groups that have been
discriminated against so according to
Hellman it may be okay to discriminate
against people whose third letter of
their last name is C like you know a
fair way to choose things is somehow
randomly like that but it it or it's at
least not compounding injustices it's
unfair to the people whose last letter
is not seen or third letters let's see
but if if that's not a group that's been
historically discriminated against maybe
it doesn't matter so for some
applications my point is that
um you really want to you care about
different certain groups and there may
even be in those applications there may
even be ways of identifying groups
um you can kind of get the Same Spirit
about the calibration which is oh I want
to know what are the groups that I care
about uh protecting even if I don't have
them identified in advance so that's in
a similar motivation
so I think just to say I think the issue
isn't necessarily identifying the groups
the issue is that you want to do
something that's not in line yeah
that's right
uh yeah you want to do something in line
with accuracy
and you don't know so there's other ways
to address this problem
um or you can think of this just as a
caveat on our paper I don't want people
to think oh therefore just minimize loss
you're Fair go you know we've checked
that box and you know uh we you know our
system is great well maybe not you know
in that in that application of matching
people to jobs you uh will have some
major problems so in applications where
you are only aligned with accuracy
um
multi calibration is probably more
aligned with those applications
um
and okay so
uh the other conclusions from this talk
are that uh basically if you're if
you're a true classifier so it's a
Wednesday when does lost minimization
give you multi-calibration not always as
we saw with the half spaces but
um if your base optimal classifier if
you're true classifier actually if the
expected value of wagon X is in your
target family great you're done and that
was known uh previously but in the case
where it's not
um if you can do exact last minute
adminization then you get
multi-calibration with respect to small
neural networks
um
but there's actually something you can
say about gradient descent and
efficiency here
um which is the following so
um I think this is kind of neat is uh
usually we think about the set of
classifiers and we want to we want to do
as well as the best classifier in the
family but
um there could be a lot of classifiers
with tons of parameters if you turn it
around there's something called probably
approximately optimal learning
um
that we that we introduced with Serbia
goel uh Sean kakade and Cyril Zhang and
the idea there is to compete compete
with a set of the algorithms look at the
architectures or algorithms and there's
a much smaller set of architectures or
algorithms the the length of the program
that you typically write to find the
best neural network the description
length of the architecture we want to
compete with the best learning algorithm
rather than the best classifier there's
no hope to complete with the best
classifier simply heart if you want you
can think of the best learning algorithm
or architecture description is constant
size
so this is kind of a cheat it's that
classic enumeration 11 style thing where
you say oh there's only so many learning
algorithms we could enumerate them all
but you could um now nowadays you don't
have to enumerate them you can run gpt3
to search through them or do some smart
architecture search but but still it's
much more reasonable to compete with
them and so then you would be comparing
you would say okay if I am searching
instead of if I'm doing an architecture
search or a search over algorithms to
find and I find the best one for
minimizing loss okay then I'm
multi-calibrated not with respect to the
best small neural network but with
respect to the best out small algorithm
small algorithm that's going to find
uh a small neural network uh does that
make sense so it's kind of a interesting
uh uh take on and and so stochastic
gradient descent would be an example of
something that you would be searching
over in your architecture search it's
not a guarantee for SGD per se it's a
guaranteed for a small small
descriptions or if you're using SGD in
both your if you're if you're forced to
use SGD in both uh the thing you're
training the large neural network for
and the thing you're searching for a
multi-calibration failures with respect
to then you should get that loss
minimization will give you that kind of
multi-calibration where it's not
multi-calibration with respect all small
neural networks it's in fact the ones
you would find by SGD
um and that's that's it so thank you
very much
[Applause]
and I'm here so you know I I hope to
have people uh you know educate me on
all the ways that this is this is wrong
or different different things that it
might be missing
thank you I said thank you for inviting
me the assignments I asked gpt3 to
finish the sentence and it said I only
wish
um we'll take half an hour break and be
back here at 3 30.